[Music]
welcome everyone my name is Jordana and
this is Scott and we're here to talk to
you about the latest innovations in
cloud data loss prevention first an
order of business we'll be using the
dory app within the cloud next app to
take questions and then at the end of
the talk we'll be going through those
Josh is our moderator and he'll be
helping you through those anything we
don't get to today
we'll be covering or responding to you
before the end of the week so in this
session we'll be giving a quick overview
of cloud data loss prevention followed
by a review of the latest things we've
launched since the last time we were
here Scott will then demo all of the new
features and then we'll end with your
questions so why are we here today for
those of you new to cloud dlp it
provides a collection of tools to
classify and detect for sensitive
information anonymize and transform text
and images and measure your protection
with risk analysis why did we build
cloud data loss prevention we made DLP
to help you understand and manage your
sensitive data we made DLP for your data
compliance officers your data engineers
your academic researchers who all need
help to assure compliance with policies
and regulations and most importantly
they need help to protect your users
data so how do we do that
DLP is made up of three pillars the
first of which is discovery in
classification a compliance officer
whose job is to ensure that credit card
data is protected can use the lp to
tokenize the data but to be really sure
they've done a thorough job they need to
conduct audits of all the persisted data
in your company to make sure that credit
cards don't show up anywhere surprising
DLP can help this compliance officer
find and identify credit card data along
with and many other types of PII across
bigquery Google Cloud storage and data
store and even data not stored
the cloud the findings can then be used
to take remediation steps such as
anonymization which takes us to our next
pillar DLP provides support to
de-identify text and images in both
structured and unstructured context we
host a number of transformation
techniques such as masking deletion and
format preserving encryption to obscure
your data while minimizing your data
loss here's an example of a user
combining the first two product pillars
as you can see we have a loan
application with several bits of PII on
the right-hand side is what the image
and what the documents look like after
they've been run through DLP as you can
see our detectors have automatically
identified the phone the email and the
social security number at the top we've
color-coded the findings so that viewers
might know what was redacted but not
what exactly private information was
there treating rich documents as images
and anonymizing in them this way is a
great technique to protect your users
data but we aren't quite done yet which
brings us to our next pillar a medical
researcher is conducting a study and
their ethics board has asked that they
remove all availability to tie the
secret lab result back to the patients
before publishing their research they've
removed all of the identifying
information the social security numbers
and the ages and the dates of birth and
they've left no direct identifiers
behind but to be sure that their
patient's identity is protected they
turn to risk analysis in this extremely
simple example we can see that there's
outliers and that in this case the job
title field is really identifying even
though normally this wouldn't be
considered PII risk analysis helps users
find data like this automatically data
that is actually very revealing if
joined with another data set we provide
a number of metrics which can increase
your understanding of the risks that
your data might pose if it were to leak
or if you were to share it intentionally
for research purposes
so those are the three pillars that make
up cloud dlp so let me tell you a little
bit about what we've launched new in the
last year DLP has a support for
detectors which are effective at finding
common types of private information and
we support custom detectors which enable
you to search for unique business data
but this new feature detection rules
allows you to refine the results found
by those detectors by modifying their
behavior to reduce noise and increase
precision let me show you two quick
examples in this case we have a data set
that we're going to be de-identifying
that has both company email addresses
those owned by my employees and customer
email addresses I don't want to redact
my employee email addresses in fact I'd
like to leave those alone and I don't
want them to show it but findings
reports by setting up setting up an
exclusion rule in this case I've just
tailed it to exclude support at
example.com from findings you can
support dictionaries here or regular
expression so that you can exclude these
from your findings and only redact your
customer email addresses here's a second
example in this data example we have a
data set that has names that we'd like
to redact the doctor names aren't
important to protect but the patient
names we need to redact because they
both show up as findings in the normal
operating mode they both be redacted as
equals but in this case I can boost the
likelihood of my patient names by
including a hot word rule that looks for
words nearby the name in this case the
word patient and I boost the certainty
and by sending min likelihood to very
likely the only names that will get
redacted or my patient names and the
doctor names will be left alone so for a
while now we've supported custom
dictionaries which were ideal when you
had a short list of secretive or
sensitive words that you wanted to scan
for but they didn't work if you had a
list of words that change frequently or
if your list was long which brings us to
stored dictionaries stored dictionaries
are easy to update and they support tens
millions of entries they're great for
things like as in the picture user ID
dictionaries there's no pattern or
regular expression I can use the detect
for these but if you give me a store a
dictionary I can find these in both your
structured and unstructured data so now
that I've given you the ability to
fine-tune your findings the next set of
features are about modifying what you
scan if you're scanning bigquery or
cloud storage scanning all of the
content may not be necessary sometimes a
million findings is no more meaningful
than one finding and it's certainly not
always the most cost effective strategy
so with this we've offered several new
ways to sample your data I'll quickly
show - very simple examples in this
example we're scanning a bigquery table
and I'm gonna limit the scan to select a
thousand rows randomly from the table
each row is about equally the same to me
and so this allows me to get a sense of
what type of private information is in
the table I can do the same thing with
Google Cloud Storage it works a little
differently in this case I give it a
bucket and I say select 25% randomly of
the files in this bucket but only scan
200 bytes of those by doing this quick
check I can completely I can check for
potential problems without incurring the
cost of exhaustive scans have I joined
this with scheduled triggers I can spot
check my buckets on a regular cadence to
assure there are no regressions as new
data is being added to my buckets
finally our biggest announcement we have
today to share with you is our launch of
the beta of our cloud dlp in the console
here you'll be able to schedule
inspection jobs manage templates and
evaluate findings which takes us to our
time to demo where Scott will show you
this UI along with all of our other new
features great I think your journey on
that so I'm gonna walk through a lot of
this that's a journey I just talked
about and show you some examples of
using our cloud dlp infrastructure kind
of an action just to get started we'll
start with our UI now there's going to
through creating an inspection job which
is a very powerful but a simple thing to
do in the UI so what we see when we get
here is we see a list of jobs that we've
run these are situations we've gone and
inspected something like bigquery or
cloud storage and we've also got a
section called job triggers those again
are jobs that you might trigger or
repeat on a regular basis so I've got a
couple examples here of jobs that are
gonna run in a regular cadence maybe you
want to run these daily weekly monthly
things like that and you can go in and
edit your templates as well what I'm
gonna start off we'll just create a job
and let's see let's call this and we're
gonna go look at cloud storage and I'm
just going to run this job I'm gonna go
find a bucket that we have here which
kind of represents a like a shared
bucket across our company has a lot of
different data in there I simply pick
the bucket I'm gonna jump into some of
the advanced configuration to show you
some of those features that Jordan
talked about first you can include an
execute path maybe there's certain file
types you don't want to scan or certain
ones you only want to scan but let's go
and jump into sampling here so I'm gonna
pick to do a random sample of the first
megabyte of every file in that bucket
and then we'll just select to scan about
50% of our of our files in the bucket so
with that simple configuration cloud dlp
we'll take care of the rest it will
basically go in scan that bucket
randomly sample the files when it finds
a file that's in the sample it's going
to only scan a random sample of the
first of the of up to one megabyte so
this gives us a good sample and now we
might have really large files in there
so it just helps us kind of get that
spot track now for detection I'm just
going to have it scan for a couple
different things here let's say we look
for credit card numbers email addresses
let's see here we'll do social security
numbers and again these are the built in
tight so just very simply I can select
them add them in and go so the next
section here is actions now actions are
basically what happens when this job
completes what do I want to do with it
we can publish a pub/sub
notification so you can pick that up and
kind of programmatically assess the
results you can save detailed findings
to bigquery this is a very common option
to do and it's very popular because you
actually get the detailed results of the
findings you can publish the Cloud
Security command center if you're
familiar with that it basically is a way
to aggregate a lot of signals into one
place or just notified by email job
status job done things like that we can
set up a schedule to run this
periodically but for this one I'm just
going to run it we get the configuration
there in case you want to use that and
let me just create the job so again it's
that easy this job is gonna run it's
gonna look for the three things that I
specified and that config and then will
be notified when it's done
but what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
jump over to a trigger that we created
earlier and so again we just scan the
kind of the company share but I wanted
to kind of walk through another common
scenario that we see which is let's
imagine that your company has a public
or a website and you've got assets that
power that website that are public and
you want to host those in a cloud
storage bucket so I'm gonna go ahead and
open up this bucket here and it's just
called company website and you'll see on
that little indicator at the top that
it's a public bucket and we're hosting
things like our images HTML CSS maybe
some videos things that we want to share
publicly but one concern I have is I
don't want to I want to make sure that
no employees go in and throw sensitive
data in that bucket because then it
would be exposed so to do that I've
created a trigger that is going to run
and I'll just kind of walk through it
that is so it's gonna basically scan
that bucket we're basically looking at
the company website bucket we're gonna
scan it recursively and we're gonna
publish the findings into bigquery so we
can look at the details what was found
where was it found and I'm also
including an option called include quote
when that does is it will actually
include the quote of the value because I
want to go in and see what was found and
I'm gonna lock down that bigquery table
this is a table under my control so I'm
gonna put that in there and lock that
down and you could run this every day
but for this we're just basically going
to run this and you can do it right now
so clicking right now here will kick off
a job and
run it right now the other thing that
I'm doing as well is I'm only scanning
the difference so let me show you what
that looks like here when you do set up
a periodic run you can basically have it
only scan new content so in this case
because it's my public website and doing
an exhaustive scan but let's say next
week when I run it again or tomorrow
when I run it again I only want to look
at things that have changed or things
that are new so the first time I ran
this we pull up that job here the first
time I ran this I ran it on the public
website I found two things I found email
address and phone number now this wasn't
too shocking because there's a public
website we expect to find something on
there so let me go ahead and look at
what that looks like so I'm gonna jump
into the details findings in bigquery
and what this does is it takes us
directly into the findings for that job
and I have a query here I'm gonna run
and as you see in this query we're
basically just selecting a few fields
and we're gonna limit it to that one job
run because I want to show what that
baseline scan look like and let's see
here just scroll this up a little bit
and if you see here we found two things
we found our company phone number and we
found a company email address not a big
deal right that's totally fine we're
happy with that they're on that
particular webpage so that's great
that's our baseline scan so what I
wanted to make sure of is that something
didn't change over time so let's jump
back and let's go back to that trigger
so when I ran this trigger again the
next time nothing was there so we just
got again no results nothing scan no new
files but then when I ran it the third
time it looks like something was in
there a bunch of data is now showed up
we saw a huge spike we saw 10,000 email
addresses 10,000 social security numbers
and we also saw this thing a hit for
what a custom type called a custom
design doc again that's very alarming
clearly this doesn't sound like
something that should be on our public
website and if we dive in and look at
the
bindings here let's just build a query
live here and I'm just going to look at
star and as we see here we're actually
seeing the raw data and this is all fake
data that we made up but in your real
scenario this is the actual data you can
see what it is you can see where it was
it looks like somebody uploaded in this
temp folder an export CSV file that
clearly has some sensitive data in it we
also had that one design doc so we want
to try to find out where that is now
what I'm doing here is I'm looking at
the raw sequel in bigquery and you can
run any kind of analytics you would run
in sequel directly here what that also
means is that you can use data studio to
visualize this data so I'm going to open
up an audit report that we built that
was built on top of that sequel query
alright and that sequel database and
I've just done some very very simple
visualization here we see we've got some
jobs that have run and I wanted to look
at this kind of results here and narrow
down where we saw that design doc so
we're gonna do a very simple filter here
and we see there's a file on in that
bucket that looks like it had a hit for
our design Doc's let's go see what that
looks like so I'm in my public bucket
here go to that temp folder we see that
export folder that had that CSV with all
the personal data we see a screenshot
folder with a bunch of screenshots and
if I open up this one screenshot what
we're seeing here is it looks like
somebody took a screenshot of our design
dock and uploaded to the website and we
have a custom type that's looking for
our design doc identifiers so we ocr'd
this doc as part of that scan found our
design doc identifier in that doc and
flagged it as a hit again that was the
custom design doc detector that we built
so very simply whether it's through
bigquery running sequel or a simple
audit report unable to get in and find
that information and identify again that
change between that baseline scan and
the next scan now I'm gonna go back to
one slide here now clearly if you have a
public bucket finding that data
monitoring for that data is very crucial
but you also might want to prevent it
from happening in the first place
you notify me finding out about it like
the day after the week after again it's
already there so you can also use DLP to
do things like scan that data before it
gets moved into the bucket this is a
reference architecture there's a link at
the bottom I know it's a little bit long
but you can find this on our website as
well it basically takes you through
using DLP and what we call kind of a
staged bucket approach where before you
move data into a public bucket you would
scan it with DLP and have the results of
that job using cloud functions actually
move the file in to the public bucket or
reject it so that's another way you can
apply this technique to prevent the data
from getting it in the first place so
now we're going to go to a different
demo we're going to go to an example of
using DLP where he used the UI as well
but we're going to apply it to do
something different we're gonna look at
bigquery and we're gonna try to use DLP
to basically classify a table so to get
started let's go look at that table and
close a couple tabs here and in this
example we have a data engineer who
uploaded a CSV file it didn't have a
header row or it just had fields 1
through 7 we don't know what's in there
now with a single table you can just
look at the table and you can figure out
what's in there but imagine if you had
thousands of these tables and you wanted
to set up a process where you could scan
it look for certain things sensitive
data and use those findings to try to
classify the table and that's what we're
gonna do today so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm gonna go back to our
DLP triggers page so I've created this
trigger and I'll walk through what that
looks like here so we're basically using
this trigger to scan a table I'll show
it from here we're basically going to be
scanning that table that I just showed
it showed now it's a big table so we
don't need to scan the whole thing we
set it up to basically do a random 10%
sample and then we're gonna use those
results and try to collect kind of
aggregate them to guess what the
classification is that table and let's
go back here
and I wanted to load the job that we ran
so when we look at the job results as
you see here we found a lot of different
things so this is just giving us a
summary of the data credit cards emails
IP addresses VIN number SSN phone number
and we also set up two custom types now
these were types similar if you if you
remember the example that driana gave
for a large custom dictionary what we
did is we set up our user IDs and we
build two big dictionaries one for our
us users and one for our European users
and in this scan it looks like we found
about 7,000 examples of us users and
3,000 of EU users and that's kind of
showing the power of these dictionaries
those dictionaries themselves had
millions and millions of data user data
in them in this case we just did a
sample scan of 10,000 rows and so we
found about you know a good 70/30
percentage of that okay so now what
we're gonna do is we're going to jump in
and let's look at the actual bigquery
table oops
let's see I'm gonna go back here and
let's just go straight from here from
the findings there we go so again in
that in that trigger what we did is we
set this up we've wrote the detailed
findings in a bigquery and now we're
going to go in and look at bigquery and
see if we can use that to understand
what's in that in that table okay so I'm
gonna load a query here and run it so
what this query is doing is it's taking
the detailed findings and it's basically
collecting all the findings you're gonna
get one row for every finding but it's
just doing a simple collect those per
field ID because you're gonna get the
field name the table column all that
stuff in there and as we see here we've
basically done that to apply the teach
field and we see that there's a good
pattern here the first column was our
user ID column had again that mix of
70/30 of US and European users we see a
VIN number email address IP address
phone number not completely so not all
of them in there hit as a phone number
SSN and credit card number so again
we're kind of walking through this
process manually what they do here is if
you had thousands of tables you could go
in and apply this sort of
programmatically and say I want to apply
this to every new
we're coming in validate the schema or
in the case of this one it really didn't
have one identify it as any sensitive
data in there and then be able to you
know get results like this okay and so
that's applying our large custom
dictionaries and also applying kind of a
unique use of it to basically go in and
classify a big query table the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to show how to apply some of our
exclusion rules and we're going to start
off by showing how you would use those
during a large inspection job like we've
been using a UI for and then right after
we're going to show how you can apply
that same template that we create in a
real time scenario so first I want to go
back to that first that first bucket
that we scanned when we kind of created
our own job so in that bucket it's a
kind of our company share a lot of
stuffs in there there's a development
folder that somebody put a lot of logs
in there and these are suppose to be
development logs that the whole company
can look at and only have test data in
them but again we're concerned something
might leak in we want to set up a
process and monitor for that data and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
go into our data loss prevention section
I have created a job trigger for this
and first I think what we're going to do
though is we are going to create we're
gonna basically do a sample scan so let
me show you the scan that we ran and
what we wanted to do is before we
exhaustively scan all of that data we
wanted to do a sample to kind of see the
things we found again we expect to find
a lot of data that we kind of don't care
about all of our test accounts so we
want to see what that looks like so what
I did is I create a job we've ran this
job only look for email addresses and
you see even in that sample we found
21,000 email addresses these are log
files not a big surprise that there's a
lot of emails in there but we want to
get a sense of what these look like so
again right from here we're gonna jump
in a big query let's run a query here
and we will see what they look like
so as we see a lot of emails are coming
in across all of our log files but they
all have this test EOP com email address
in there which is our test accounts so
we're we're good we're happy with that
but again if I've run this job every day
and it comes up with 21,000 findings or
30,000 findings it's not gonna be very
useful for me when most of those are
ones I don't care about so we're gonna
do is we're gonna go back and we're
gonna create an exclusion template so
I'm gonna show you what that looks like
we're gonna show a code sample here what
I'm doing here is I'm using our API
Explorer I'm gonna pull up and show you
kind of in detail what that looks like
and how simple it is so in this example
we're showing kind of the JSON
representation of a template and we
simply turned on three types that we
cared about email address credit card
and social security number and at the
bottom we created a rule an exclusion
rule that simply says if you see test LP
comm in the result of an email address
partial match just ignore it that way
the prefix the username whatever it is
we don't care
it'll match on the on the suffix and
we'll be good you leave that one up go
to my job triggers page so that's the
template that we want to use now for our
ongoing periodic scan and that way the
findings that we get will be meaningful
to us so we set those up in a template I
mean a trigger we are going to use this
email exclude template that we just
created that we just showed you
we're gonna do a exhaustive scan now
because again we want to make sure that
there isn't that one email address or
two email address it's leaking into our
logs so we did the sample scan to figure
out what's going on get a sense of what
was there now we did the exhaustive scan
to search for everything and let's see
what happened we're gonna open up the
job and it looks like we found two email
addresses so this is actually useful
right we went from 21,000 and in a small
sample scan and now we scanned about you
know six hundred and twenty twenty six
megabytes of log files that are up there
and we found two email addresses so
these are probably ones we've really
care about and want to go look at so I'm
gonna jump into the findings here
[Music]
and just open up this saved query what
I'm doing here is I'm basically looking
at just the results here for that last
scan that we did and again it's a sample
data here but these are two that are not
part of our test set it's the same email
address showed up twice in this one log
prod test log five so clearly that prod
test log five maybe wasn't a dev blog
and shouldn't have been in there and
again we've been able to very easily
identify that using exclusion list
weeding out all the stuff we didn't care
about now to do that again we use this
exclusion rule we applied it to when we
did this large scan where we basically
went in scan 600 and something megabytes
of data applied it in a large operation
but that template is very useful again
that that holds the configuration of
what you care about what you're looking
for what we're gonna do next is we're
gonna use that template and we're gonna
apply it in another scenario we're gonna
show how that same template and same
exclusion rule can be used in real time
to do that I'm going to pull open a
sample application that we built and I'm
just going to load this is a live
classification demo that we built on App
Engine what it's doing is it's taking
the data that's on the Left box and
automatically applying one of our DLP
inspection and transforms and then
putting the output in the right box so
what we see here is a sample chat where
we've got one of our agents talking to a
customer and we've simply said look for
a bunch of stuff and just redact it when
you find it so on the right side you see
all the emails were replaced with email
address SS ends with the US social
security number and credit cards
replaced but again we want to apply that
template now because we didn't really
want to hide our agents name we want to
know who that is and in this case the
James at St OPM was hidden because we
just treated it as an email address what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to go in here
I'm gonna load this template this is the
that's the template name I'm gonna take
this template name that we created
and in our live kind of real-time demo
we have the ability just to paste in a
template so we're showing we're not
going to go edit the code we're just
simply going to have the the application
use a different template I'm going to
paste it in here and so now if I go back
to this and update it what you see is
the right side refreshed as soon as I
type something in and now we are no
longer excluding the James at stlp com
so again just showing that that one same
template that we created from copied
straight from the inspect job applied
here you can use it in all of your kind
of pipelines and workflows and have that
consistency and not have to go in and
change code just simply reference a
different resource again that's showing
our exclusion rules there's a lot more
power that you can do as well creating
your own custom types exclusion rules
combining those together all of that
again no matter how simple or complex it
is can be saved as a template and then
reused across your workload
[Music]